- When I was hungover
in a test in college,
I once spelled quarterback with a C.
(laughing)
So that gives you some...
- I think when it comes
to spelling for me,
I like peaked in 5th grade.
- Overall, I'd say I'm
a pretty decent speller.
- Am I gonna have to spell in my head?
Oh god, this is the
worst thing in the world!
- I hope I do better than
I think that I'll do.
- Misspelled.
- M-I-S, I feel like
people, oh wait, alright.
- M-I-S-P-E-L-L-E-D.
(buzzer)
Are there two S's?
- P-E-L-L-E-D. (buzzer)
Damn it, it's two S's, isn't it?
- M-I-S-S-P-E-L-L-E-D. (bell dings)
- L-L-E-D. (bell dings)
- Oh god!
- I think I got that one.
Guarantee, G-U-A-R-E-N-T-E-E.
(buzzer)
What, that's bullshit.
- G-U-A-R, how do little kids do this
without writing it out?
- G-U-A-R-A-N-T-E-E, Guarantee.
(bell dings)
- [Interviewer] Nailed it.
- T-E-E, (bell dings) that was right?
- A-N-T-E-E. (bell dings)
- I can't spell millennial.
I really don't know how to spell it.
- M-I-E-N,
wait, no.
- M-I-L-L-E-N-I-A-L. (buzzer)
Oh you see, it's all the double,
that's just the only thing.
Is there like partial credit?
- E-N-I-A-L. (buzzer)
- E-I-A-L. (buzzer)
No, really?
- Oh, jesus.
- I read a lot of bar menus
so hopefully I can get this
one based on muscle memory.
- D-A-Q,
Daiquiri.
- D-A-Q-U-I-R-I. (buzzer)
- I-R-I, (buzzer) Daiquiri?
- Q-U-E-R-I-E. (buzzer)
- E-I-R-I. (buzzer)
Not even close.
- Why, who came up with that?
- This is brutal.
I was not expecting to do this bad.
- Yeah, I surprised myself.
I'm thrilled right now.
Who needs spellcheck?
- But I'm gonna remember this forever.
I'm gonna remember all of these words.
You like test me in 10 years
and I will remember every
single one of these.